now that the war with Italy was over the
one against the Saxons which had been
interrupted for the time being was taken
up once more no war ever undertaken by
the Frankish people was more prolonged
more full of atrocities or more
demanding of effort the Saxons
like almost all the people living in
Germany are ferocious by nature they are
much given to devil worship and they are
hostile to our religion they think it no
dishonor to violate and transgress the
laws of God and man hardly a day passed
without some incident or other which was
well calculated to break the peace our
brothers and theirs were contiguous and
nearly everywhere in flat open country
except indeed for a few places where
great forests or mountain ranges
interposed to separate the territories
of the two people by a clear demarcation
line murder robbery and arson were of
constant occurrence on both sides in the
end the Franks was so irritated by these
incidents that they decided that the
time had come to abandon retaliatory
measures and to undertake a full-scale
war against the Saxons
war was duly declared against them
it was waged for 33 long years and with
immense hatred on both sides but the
losses of the Saxons were greater than
those of the Franks this war could have
been brought to a more rapid conclusion
had it not been for the faithlessness of
the Saxons it was hard to say just how
many times they were beaten and
surrended as suppliants to Charlemagne
promising to do all the was exalted from
them giving the hostages who were
demanded and this without delay and
receiving the ambassador's who were sent
to them sometimes they were so cowed and
reduced that they even promised to
abandon their devil-worship that submit
willingly to the Christian faith but
however ready they might seem from time
to time to do all this they were always
prepared to break the promises they had
made I cannot really judge which of
these two courses can be said to have
come the more easily to the Saxons for
since the very beginning of the war
against them hardly a year passed in
which they did not vacillate between
surrender and defiance
however the Kings mettlesome spirit and
his imperturbable 'ti which remained as
constant in adversity as in prosperity
were not to be quelled by their
ever-changing tactics or indeed to be
wearied by a task which he had
undertaken not once did he allow anyone
who had offended in this way to go
unpunished
he took vengeance on them for their
perfect and meted out suitable
punishment either by means of an army
which he led himself or by dispatching
of force against them under the command
of his counts in the end when all those
who'd been offering resistance had been
utterly defeated and subjected to his
power he transported some 10,000 men
taken from among those who lived on both
side of the river elbe and across the
river and dispersed them in small groups
with their wives and children in various
parts of Gaul and Germany at long last
this war which it dragged on for so many
years came to an end on conditions
imposed by the king and accepted by the
Saxons
these last were to give up their devil
worship and the malpractice is inherited
from their forefathers and then once
they had adopted the sacraments of the
Christian faith or religion they were to
be united with the Franks and become one
people with them
[Music]
[Music]